Rockets shooting from where? Watching
your dad's head get lopped off by a Jedi
is bound to mess you up, but how does the new
ruler of Jabba's Palace define himself today?
Even by the standards of other
bounty hunters in Mandalorian armor,
Boba Fett has a special relationship with deadly
gadgets. Fett's jetpack comes complete with a
missile that can take down entire ships.
His armor comes equipped with special knee
rockets he can fire while walking toward his
targets. In several non-canonical stories,
it's established that Boba Fett's
signature helmet, aside from looking cool,
also gives him 360-degree vision. While this
didn't seem to help him avoid Han Solo's blind
attack in "Return of the Jedi," this feature may
make a return in Fett's new canonical stories.
Considering how Boba Fett's armor makes him
a one-man army, it's no wonder that Marshal
Cobb Vanth was reluctant to part with the
armor in the season 2 "Mandalorian" episode
"The Marshal." Even among Mandalorians, Boba
Fett's tools make him a force to be reckoned with.
The "Star Wars" universe is a rough
place where you have to fight dirty,
but sometimes Boba Fett makes fighting dirty
downright filthy. Initially, this was only
hinted at in "The Empire Strikes Back" when
Darth Vader singles out Fett by telling him
that there will be "no disintegrations."
In the canon comic book story "Star Wars:
Age of Republic —Jango Fett" #1, a 10-year-old
Boba executes two experienced bounty hunters when
they try to take him hostage, proving he had
the ability to be brutal even at a young age.
But it's in "The Mandalorian" season 2 episode
"The Tragedy" that we learn just how merciless
Boba Fett is with his targets. Stripped of his
armor, Boba uses a Tusken Raider gaderffii stick
against a squad of Stormtroopers who probably
all wish he would just disintegrate them. Fett
caves in their skulls and brutally
impales them with his melee weapon,
giving them some of the most painful-looking
deaths in "Star Wars" history. Later,
he recovers his armor and takes out the remaining
Stormtroopers with bombs, blaster shots,
knee rockets, and a very well-placed jetpack
missile. By the end of this scene, everyone knows
that when Boba Fett has you in his sights, you can
forget about running away. You're already dead.
"Star Wars" characters face adversity all
the time, but few of them face it as much
as Boba Fett, whose entire life seems to
be fighting with his back against the wall.
While Boba receives training and guidance from his
father Jango for the first few years of his life,
he essentially needs to make it on his own
from the age of 10 after he's orphaned in
the Battle of Geonosis. He chooses to make it
in the cutthroat world of bounty hunting. Then,
at the height of his reputation, he falls
into the Sarlacc pit in "Return of the Jedi"
and must keep himself from being slowly
digested over the next thousand years.
Yet somehow Fett survives all of these impossible
odds, adding to the aura of danger and mystique
around him. When we see him in the end credits
scene of The Mandalorian episode "The Rescue,"
he's seemingly acquired a position of great
power as the new crime boss of Tatooine,
but it's basically a given that
this will require him to perform
even more impossible feats when
"The Book of Boba Fett" debuts.
Boba Fett may have initially shown
up in the service of the Empire,
but he quickly establishes that he's really
just following the money, and in it for himself.
Shortly after tracking Han Solo to Bespin
for Darth Vader in "The Empire Strikes Back,"
Fett collects the bounty on Captain Solo
by turning in his carbonite-frozen form
to the Tatooine crime lord Jabba the Hutt in
"Return of the Jedi." He remains in Jabba's
employ until he falls in the Sarlacc pit,
and then roams the galaxy alone, eventually
forming a temporary alliance with Mandalorian
Din Djarin against the remains of the Empire.
As Fett clearly states to Din Djarin in "The
Mandalorian" season 2 episode "The Tragedy,"
"I give my allegiance to no one."
Unlike Mandalorians, who follow a specific creed
that dictates their actions, Boba Fett makes his
own rules. This might make him unpopular, but for
this bounty hunter, it's the only way to live.
Of course, just because Boba Fett lives by
his own rules doesn't mean he's an entirely
lawless man. He may be brutal, but he will honor
the terms of any deals he makes with others.
Sometimes those deals are formal contracts he
makes with regimes like the Empire or powerful
men like Darth Vader. Other times, they're verbal
agreements he offers to bounty hunters like Din
Djarin, which places him in the Mandalorian's
debt until he helps him save the Child known as
Grogu. Either way, Boba Fett shows he will stand
by deals made with his employers and allies.
That said, once the terms of the deal are complete
or his employers try to stab him in the back,
all bets are off. Fett may have been working
for Darth Vader in "The Empire Strikes Back,"
but he has no problem killing Stormtroopers or
blowing up TIE Fighters in "The Mandalorian"
once he enters into a new deal with Din
Djarin. He may be a dangerous mercenary,
but as long as he's working for
you, Boba Fett will go the distance.
Until Boba Fett acquires a partner in Fennec Shand
after he saves her following the events of The
Mandalorian season 1 episode "The Gunslinger," he
usually travels alone. Nevertheless, this bounty
hunter is far from a man without a past or a
family. While he doesn't necessarily identify
as a Mandalorian, Fett is proud of his family
line and identifies strongly as Jango Fett's son.
This causes him to respond with extreme
anger if someone tries to write him off
as just another Clone Trooper. He gets into a
violent brawl with Koska Reeves after she and
Bo-Katan sneer at his clone origins in
"The Mandalorian" episode "The Rescue."
He also takes great pride in showing Din
Djarin the record of his family tree stored
in his armor, which just provides him with an
additional reason to reclaim his famous suit.
If there's one thing that distinguishes Boba Fett,
it's his trademark Mandalorian armor. While there
are now multiple Mandalorian bounty hunters and
warriors running around the "Star Wars" universe,
there's just something about Fett's battle-scarred
green and gray armor that tells people they're in
the presence of a dangerous man with a very
personal connection to his chosen wardrobe.
"I don't want your armor. I want my armor."
In recent episodes of "The Mandalorian,"
Fett has cleaned up the scratches and blaster
marks from his armor, and re-established the
important reasons for wearing this particular
suit. While Boba Fett clearly has the means
to have a new armored suit built for him,
he insists on tracking down his original armor.
The suit initially belonged to Jango Fett, after
all, and is his strongest link to his father.
For someone who's lost as much as Boba
Fett, his armor truly is irreplaceable.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite bounty hunters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.